foreign
there are so many strong opinions about
how bad the internet has become
how it is weaponized mediocrity
normalize Miss and disinformation
but for me
the information superhighway
has always been my savior
as a little boy I was sent from Nigeria
to boarding school in the English
Countryside
it was like Harry Potter without the
magic
it was a confusing and troubling time
for an already sensitive little boy who
was Far From Home
I was
more like
an exotic animal in a petting zoo
rather than a student
and to top it off I'm dyslexic
and today what will be described as
neurodiverse
which for me meant that the classroom
was impossibly slow and my brain was not
capable of assimilating how they were
teaching me
so for a big part of my life
I was ashamed of my own mind
and if I'm being honest
I was ashamed of myself
luckily the internet had other ideas
every time I consumed something online
my brain felt alive
it was an Awakening of sorts
and
luckily for me I am the right age to
have discovered the internet in that
very very moment
so what did I start doing I started
realizing how my mind worked
how I could assimilate audio visual
experiences into sleep
how
I could name a song within the first
second or the first note
or talk about scenes in films like I
lived them
and how overwhelmingly powerful
artistic experiences were for me
this became my savior
and I wanted to share it with my friends
so
pop ballads like more than words
by extreme
Street poetry like Brenda's Baby by
Tupac
films like The Last of the Mohicans
Love Jones
and of course Cinema Paradiso
these experiences were way more than
entertainment for me
I was being raised by these experiences
and I needed to share it with as many
people as possible so my friends would
come with their hard drives and I would
download and share pictures and poetry
and film for them
for me the internet had become
an endless library of the extraordinary
and I didn't just have the keys to this
Library I lived there
we will talk about Fela kuti Johnny
Mitchell Neil Young
these were my heroes these were the
souls that have found the blueprint
of how to do and win in this thing
called life
it also saved my mental health
the dancing
of Misha barishnikov
was for me like watching a perfect
sunset
the voice of Sarah Vaughan
was my North Star
and of course the words
of Pablo Neruda
well that will always be medicine for my
soul
so
how did I get to be this great Observer
of content
and become an artist
it was just sharing images and one of
the images I shared all the time was
this image
of Coretta Scott King
this image was taken by monida sleet Jr
the first black man to win a Pulitzer
for photography
this image almost didn't happen because
unbelievably
no black media was invited
to photograph the funeral of Dr Martin
Luther King
when Coretta Scott realized
she said no one's coming into this
church if men need asleep is not allowed
and thank the heavens that he was
because it was his lens that captured
the grace
and somehow on an unimaginable day the
strength
of Coretta Scott's King on the funeral
of her husband with her baby girl
Bernice
in her lap
it was this image that taught me the
photography can be way more than wedding
picks and birthday snaps it was this
image that let me know that at his best
photography can let us know the work
that we need to do
so
how did I become an actual photographer
well the answer of that is love
my wife
we fell in love
together
by feeling each other's invisible scars
like Braille
she fell in love with all the parts of
myself
that I was ashamed of
she looked beyond my anxiety my imposter
syndrome
and she saw a man that maybe had a point
of view himself so she bought me a
camera
for my 40th birthday
just five years ago
so I have a camera now I don't know what
to do with it and once again I go online
and I teach myself about ISO and
aperture on YouTube I teach myself
about editing with Adobe Lightroom on
YouTube
and there's a great Beauty for someone
like me to be able to fail and fail in
my little office online watching free
tutorials this is a gift of the internet
everything changed when my daughter was
born
you see the thing about not loving
yourself
is that when something truly great
something Celestial like a child comes
into your life
you tell yourself you don't deserve it
my daughter was premature
and I was terrified to be the custodian
as something so beautifully precious so
I hid
behind my camera
and as I kept taking pictures of this
little soul and as she got stronger the
camera and my daughter taught me how to
receive love
and taught me to accept
the immense Grace and privilege of being
a father
this was the most important moment in my
photographic Journey
two years later in 2020 George Floyd was
killed
and all of us
saw that because of the power of social
media
and this time we refused to look away
I looked to my wife and I said I have
run out of Tears
and she said look to your camera
and I took my camera to the Streets of
London not knowing if I would photograph
five people or five thousand
and I was able to observe one of the
greatest
civil rights movements In Our Lifetime
the global protests after the death of
George Floyd
is something none of us would have
expected and my lens was there
one morning I woke up and I couldn't
open my phone
because I had so many notifications
the Sun
of Coretta Scott King Martin Luther King
III
had somehow come across one of my images
and posted it on his Twitter
and then the world
discovered me
millions of people saw these images and
now
unbelievably British Vogue Came Calling
and they commissioned a then unknown
photographer to shoot the September
issue of British Road
2020 and in doing so I became the first
black man to shoot any cover for British
Rogue
it took 104 years to get to my cover
since then I've had this extraordinary
career photographing amazing humans
amazing moments
but beyond all the glitz and all the
glamor it is really important for me
to recognize the intentionality and the
empathy of where my lens must look
the world is burning right now
and we cannot pass each other by like
ships in the night so
my lens has to look to where voices need
to be lifted
I recently have become an ambassador for
saver children
and I went to Somaliland to cover the
famine
the hunger crisis that is in the Horn of
Africa
these brave people are suffering because
of climate change or which something
something that they add very little to
many of the children are born into a
hellscape that is not of their making
1.6 million children
on the verge of acute malnutrition and I
want my images
to let you know that you cannot say you
did not know
so I ask you to use whatever levers of
power that you have at dinner parties on
your social media
speak to those that can do something
about it if you cannot yourself
I will finish by saying this
do not be afraid
to take The Road Less Traveled
where your vulnerability with pride
It Is What Makes Us human
this age of perceived perfection
it's over
very few of us are okay
and that's okay
and to the parents
and teachers that are looking after
children
with different Minds please let them
know about the power and possibility of
their minds
because they may have the answers that
will allow all of us to look toward the
Horizon together
thank you
foreign